[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
are we live
hey guys I'm a Sam here here with
Michael hi um hi hi Erik if you're here
where is like a preview of what's live
right now because I don't see a screen
up here oh if you guys are here and
you're watching us we're gonna be
playing for tonight today to review the
update yeah but also I don't do you see
where we're live right now because there
we are okay so we are okay thanks
Michael sure all right well now we're
we're doing this we're playing fortnight
yes battle royale five point two point
oh two point five point oh two point
five point okay mout yesterday if you
guys are playing yeah we just updated
now and we're going to play some of it I
mean it's more or less the same game i
if you saw on GameSpot calm the
different things that they change they
took out smg's for a little while so we
can test out new weapons they have some
new things that kind of commemorate
Lunar New Year Chinese New Year and so
there's some of that some new item that
grenade hopefully we can find that and
put it to good use out for tonight about
four hours last night to try to feel it
out and yeah it's it's a fun game yeah I
I guess I'm on here because I have the
most experience which I don't know we'll
see y'all saw me last time with Eric I
was I was whooping on them but let's see
if we can do that again yeah alright
let's jump into this we good Sam you
good
did they update this morning I thought
they updated yesterday but I did play
last night so I just booted up a client
the epic games client and then it
started updating the game so yeah so I
am a when did you start playing for
tonight first off probably I would say
two months ago I jumped into the battle
royale mode because I coming off pub G
like I was just playing Bob G all day
with my homies back home and
in the office here and then I was like I
think that most pub key players looked
at fortnight Battle Royale and said like
oh this is a clone like and then kind of
wrote it off but then actually jumped
into it and then you can play like I
mentioned before you can play this like
pub G but can it only get you so far
because building is the more you play it
the more you realize how important it is
to build and once you get to get the
hang of that then it's a completely
different game
well conceptually it's very similar but
I mean the way this game plays out
towards the end of the match it's wild
yeah it's very very different
I actually I started playing
battlegrounds about I want to say more
than six months ago for sure I have
about 130 or 40 hours in the game y'all
yeah and a lot of people who are really
into battlegrounds kind of like talk
poorly about fortnight or being a clone
or being a rip off and I I'm not gonna
lie I totally subscribe to that line of
thinking for a long time and I was like
it is because I like didn't I didn't
actually give it a shot mmm-hmm I was
just like and it's just a clone yeah it
came out in such quick succession after
after pub she kind of blew up it's like
Oh who's gonna be the first oh this is
the first one to do it so yeah and then
I actually so last yesterday I played it
for four hours and at first I was like
tomato town this is yeah I was just like
this is stupid this is like for children
and then all of a sudden I started
having a lot of fun and I was like oh no
oh no they got me they got me so and it
is actually a completely different game
in the end for sure I was like amazed
watching the people build like yeah it's
we filled a game audio is loud enough if
you know yours are watching let me know
if you need the game audio adjusted you
keep me posted on that you don't need to
build to win sauce blaster says you
don't need to build a win you could
probably you can I'm you can still win
without building but a good luck like
you know I I guess you could build if
you jump I mean you could win if you
jump a lot like you would have to just
be like flying all over the place maybe
if you got lucky and you got matched in
a group of people who were just really
scrubby I haven't had that kind of luck
quite yet but I don't know yeah it's
like every time I make it to the top ten
it's like everyone's got their towers
and stuff and you if you got a get a
good shot off and maybe you can get him
out of there their forts or catch him
slipping when they're trying to like
move to a new circle I mean you can do
that I just increased the game out of
you guys it should be a little bit
better for you guys yeah so I am in this
this trailer park that ain't got a damn
thing well I got a burst rifle but
bursar F is kind of trash okay so I read
I'm I'm not gonna front
I read the beginners tips on games much
like on them because I was I know and I
was like
I realize did you I realized that those
were a little too beginner for me if
you've played battle royale games you
don't need the intercepts but I did look
at like some of our other guides pages
and do you feel like it's good to have
for the two weapons for like the pump
shotgun and the sniper too hot like if
you do pick up two and you put them in
the slots next to each other it does cut
the reload time between the two is that
like an actual strategy people do that
is I don't know it's um I mean I read
that I never tried it in action yeah I
mean either but uh I don't know if hey
that's how do you feel I'm gonna ask you
all types of newbie questions right now
sure because I'm like I might not have
answers we'll see I saw fool over here
building some [ __ ] I'm about the I'm
gonna ruin his day what's up no I just
wanted to know what your favorite weapon
weapon is and is the pump shotgun like
not worth because I felt like the reload
time was like really high like I went to
shoot somebody they did not die I had to
reload it took a very long time
and I was sitting there like taking so
long and I got I got killed my favorite
weapon would be I mean I just rape use
assault rifles not not the burst
I don't like the burst rifle but the
thing I brought up before Keith Richards
liver says they call that the double
pump thank you thank you for that the
little pump Phillip and knack and naku
says people still play this actually a
lot of people still play this this
growing yeah this is the game right now
probably because it's free-to-play yeah
definitely we yeah we touched on that in
our fortnight popularity discussion
video it's like you know it's free like
an email skin off your back if you don't
like it like other than if you got data
caps then haha my bad but yeah if you
don't and it's like you know try it out
if you like it it's not peace like where
as pub G is like you know you got to pay
30 bucks
yeah infamous Jim asked earlier so what
happened to the pub she lost you I
actually didn't even know there was a
pub she lawsuit no that was awesome I
Matt Padgett did a very good video about
that and he talked to videogame attorney
thing his name is that guy oh my god
yeah yeah yeah he interviewed him about
it and but I don't think that particular
lawsuit or whatever went anywhere got it
other than saying like y'all stole ours
stole our idea Oh welcome to the
GameSpot stream thank you for coming
yeah if y'all just joining us y'all
about to see some pro level for a night
play so I ain't got no damn resources
and so please gamer says he actually
bought the game when it first came out
to support that is that's right although
I think they're doing to find out they
have a huge player base making a lot of
money's they came out all those fun
skins and cosmetic items for Valentine's
Day I saw a lot of people rocking those
last night yeah lots of lots of cupids
running around
I'd love to survive this match though I
hear some [ __ ] going down but like you
just have to just rush I don't know like
you don't have a lot of wood I'm just
saying yeah you're right like you should
probably fix remedy that situation I
just like run through the houses just
pillaging things that's what I do yeah
that's probably I think usually you're
like walking around like that burned me
though when I was playing last stream
with Eric I'll just like I was like
whacking things with my pickaxe and then
some fools like run up on me because
they can hear you that's one of the
beginner strats or whatever it's like oh
you know gather resources if as long as
you're safe well I never really know
when I'm safe so that's me all the time
I'm getting blasted home alright alright
look at him hmm all right if y'all wanna
look how fancy he looks oh my god yes
way this is like Kingdom Come
deliverance right now yeah you watch
that stream lastly yesterday that was oh
my god else like I was trying to work
and then I was watching Peter and Rob
and I'm just like dying at my desk I'm
like laughing yeah yeah the creepy pink
bear is please camera yes those papers
are scary also like kind of defeats the
purpose of trying to be like you know
stealthy at all although I will write
for tonight is not about what I learned
very quickly is for it it is a game that
does not care about stealth at all yeah
I think I think stealth is not the right
way to put it it's more about like
keeping a low profile in certain
situations yeah you either you either
keep a little profile or you basically
tell everyone you're like you know I'm
staking it out right here come at me
yeah I saw something crazy I saw it last
night in my games I saw some crazy
building happening and I was like how
are they what are they I'm still getting
the hang of the building the most I do
is I build ramps up into infinity and
then I just fall off of them eventually
yeah that's what I do or like I fight
look at this pool oh oh oh it's gross
dude don't do that so I'm gonna take a
moment to go through some of the changes
outline in a patch nurture let us know
what were what what we're getting new
with this new for weapons and items they
added the impulse grenade it's a blue
rarity found in treasure chests and
supply drops only the scoped assault
rifle is now perfectly accurate loss
coped my question is I why wasn't it
before it no it's just the the accuracy
models of this game are like all over
the place it wasn't really it was this
game was never really about precision
like in terms of aiming and shooting but
I think they're trying to adjust to that
now that you know cuz this style of
games
Battle Royale like totally could use a
little bit more precision I suppose we
also have a scope assault rifle headshot
damage decrease from 250 to 200 percent
I guess it was Opie and they decided to
nerf it or maybe they wanted to adjust
for the increased accuracy right who
knows revolver now uses medium ammo
crossbow dropped chances decreased by
20% mini Cup draw minigun dropped chance
decreased by 12.5% chug chug dropped
chance decreased by 15% no Chuck jugs no
were yeah the white green blue SMG is
rotating out and heading into the ball
and I heard about the SMG change like
they were taking out the SMG only
temporarily to adjust it because it was
too good really that's that I read that
that's true I'm probably just trash but
I was like I never really had I didn't
have a good luck with the SMG but that's
probably because I'm trash but
expectations' low but overperform this
what's the motto
what else would I hope what else so they
fixed issue fix a few issues here fix
cypher rifles occasionally not
registering hits when aiming downward
with high network latency
they're fixed an issue with projector I
was failing to hit nearby players when
hitting another target fix an issue
allowing players to fire around walls
with the crossbow and a minigun if they
stood very close to the edge of the wall
those are the reload failed messages
will no longer display on weapons that
do not have a clip to reload ie minigun
I think that makes sense and they
removed purple at rounding on shotgun
damage calculation damage was rounded
down to the nearest whole number for
each individual pellet instead of all
projectiles will be added together
before rounding they've also fixed an
issue which caused the mini guns barrel
to continue to glow after use whew oh no
they removed it for being bad Wow yeah I
was about to say like because I did not
have any luck with that it was like do a
little like 1013 damage I mean I got
time for that I may have made my
assessment off of some comments that
were being made by about the SMG so it
was somebody being like good I kept
dying to the SMG there's a lot about
that player right so yeah I totally made
that Oh
oh hey square up let's go
oh my god come on I'm a CS pro I come on
let's go run for home like this is this
is not the way play chasing fools and
[ __ ] that was a that fools at 10 health
mitt mmm
all right chat let's count that as a
kill psyche I'm just playing what weapon
was that I had a regular out of common
assault rifle so and then like a green
shotguns like hoo boy well I believed in
myself and got 58 wins I think you just
need to I believed in myself and then I
got zero wins you didn't believe in
yourself Michael alright alright so you
literally went into that I know ya know
eight okay alright I feel I feel you on
this you need to go in and be like I'm a
hot-shit best yes it is i Michael hi I'm
the best who will win this battle royale
so yeah alright so i'm gonna win this
battle royale and i think you know to be
a winner you have to think like a winner
right so i'm gonna think like a winner
periscope chat is asking to show the new
skins there were some new skins so after
this round we will go through and look
at the new skins
can we I think we can view them I don't
know if we can if you all want to see
the skins right now it's up on gamespot
comm Chris shout-out to Chris Pereira he
put together the article to outline the
changes in the new patch and in the in
the article there's an image of the new
skins so if you y'all can check that out
right now
but don't get off the string Blood Money
asks why they took out the SMG
apparently it's cuz it's bad they're
reworking it and they're gonna put it
back in the game so I have seen
conflicting opinions up by players I
don't I haven't read anything
I mean I'm even looking at the patch
notes right now and if they don't say
why they took it out they just said
took it out of rotation yeah they're
talking to you like yeah well we took it
out cuz it's bad all right I won't put
it back all right
yeah I mean I'm sure that you can read
more about that so for world
oh this was another thing they fixed a
they fixed supply drops hovering midair
if the object beneath them was destroyed
okay
and they also fixed shield hit effects
playing when taking failing falling
damage and the last fix was a possible
crash that occurred while firing weapons
before boarding at the battle bus oh so
you can crash if you crash out of your
games before boarding the battle bus I
might have been why they fixed it so I'm
gonna like to skip over some of the UI
in performance they optimized player
animations to improve frame rate same
with the dusting shield effects dust
cloud and shield effects on low settings
eliminated various hitches that cause
skins items to be loaded at unexpected
times character models weapons
environment assets they now utilize a
level of detail system to improve
performance so a bunch of things to
smooth at and improve performance major
tweaks to FX settings as well yeah so a
lot of it seems like they did lots of
lot of small stuff gentle gentle fixes
to increase performance and improve
performance
a lot of audio adjustments as well
that's cool yeah it's like you know you
don't want your game to be rough around
the edges like some game and these are
known issues with the update weapon
crosshairs will disappear sometimes
after using a scoped weapon weapons will
sometime appear to be loaded but cannot
be fired oh that's a really that's a
great bug to introduce into this update
and in rare cases an item dropped by an
eliminated player cannot be picked up by
other players so those are some problems
you might face in this update according
to the patch notes all right that's fair
enough yeah all right so there's there's
isawful going up here oh snap I'm about
to get the jump on it off there we go
yes Lord vixx it appears that the lag
when you jump off the bus has been fixed
well that's what they say I saw fool
walk up into this building so maybe I'm
tripping I don't I don't I don't think
you're tripping I think it's probably in
there smash smash the ceiling I also I
was trying to maybe he's behind here
psych oh man maybe it's just my
imagination my mind is playing tricks oh
snap it's never your imagination oh look
there he is get him the hell my eyes
messed up I can't oh I'm gonna go for
that potion first drink up pull up all
stop slurp juice okay so so shy lush
romani I'm sorry if I botched your name
I'm great about doing that is the double
pump shotgun thing is that a real strat
that people use and it is it effective
just go between like slots two slots
with the shotgun to eliminate loading
time I don't know you're asking okay
Michael
all right
well I went in here I was talking about
no you're not the only one
all right more good jump a lot yeah I
know this isn't a good showing man you
know miss Warren customer knows I'm
submit so far the things I've heard of
not hold up yeah I'm not gonna lie I'm I
have not been performing quite as good
as I had hoped or have done in the past
what what did what did I tell you about
me he told he told me that hey you know
who you should ask to play for tonight
with you today our resident for tonight
god Michael hi um that's what I heard
you know sometimes you just have bad
days we have 367 people watching on
periscope if you are watching a
periscope hello thank you for joining us
today playing the new for tonight update
they want skin skin skin oh darn it dang
I'm sorry I could I could just like
bring up I don't I don't know how I
would do this oh I can barely I think
well cuz then I'm gonna swap out with
Eric yes when Eric comes in we'll go
through this game yes probably
poor Eric Keowee every day that I've so
far every time I've dreamed he comes and
he's okay so this is how you do it and
I'm like okay cool I got it got that
what you really don't know nope so two
buttons that's my stuff right now we
should listen to old man Tay old man Tay
eight a site ultra kick gamer says SMG
OS o P so C give the SMG LM so Jaws jaws
and ultra kit the SMG is gone sorry
they're still like some smg's in the
game I guess is it I don't know the SMG
they removed is me because there's like
different types let's see if I'm talking
to Erica earlier he's like this
different types of G's I'm like is there
really no the white green blue SMG is
rotating out okay Elsa
yeah tactical a SMG still I which was I
was using earlier which got me rekt oh
my God look all right let's play some
let's play a little spicy here so
something else I notice with that was
different with for tonight is the way
that the parachute drop works it's so
much harder to get on the ground
like with pub G you know exactly how to
get exactly where you want to go for
tonight from the moment that you drop
that parachute it's like alright here is
the long and wiggly descent to the
ground that's right oh I think that's
the fastest I've ever been killed you on
see nothing on to the next match but
yeah like the oppression I mean I think
what I like in this game is that you can
actually like go far distances in your
parachute rather than in pubs I can't
really think if you good item shop you
can see that it's
Oh teddy bear so these are the featured
items I don't know how to actually that
looks creepiest but that's a creepy
[ __ ] so these I saw these these are the
Valentine's Day stuff that came out
cosmetics that came out and I saw a ton
of them in the game yesterday
and those are a limited time yes cool
well shouts out to GameSpot in the chat
and calling me calling me out my skills
oh I don't let them get to you Michael
I believed in you when I step back into
that office people are gonna look at me
like yo what's wrong with you you're
just setting me up to look great okay
that's what this is really about and I'm
setting the bar real low for you a few
hours so I'm doing you a favor
really thank you so except for it in
this round because I'm bout to mmm boy
the warm-up round before this I was I
could have sworn I was the top five I
was wrecking pools like Shay lush says I
miss chat twice what did I miss
skins I think it's are we talking about
the skins because we are gonna be
looking at some skins soon yes the girl
for a little while maybe maybe after
this match if I get a if I get a good
round in I might step out after that and
then take and take over but uh first I
got to put in the work and y'all gonna
watch me put in the work Wow take hold
you out in the chat he said I would
never call hi I'm a god mmm
he is a filthy casual that's that's him
talking all that whoa whoa hey guys my
name is Sam and I'm here to spread
falsehoods
about Michael hi um I'm just I'm just
kidding it's not the first time people
be doing that haters going hey man let's
get a burger all right so hopefully we
can get some some dope drops here
because I have not had
that much look with my drops or picking
stuff up have you been playing mostly
for nigh on PC or ps4 PC whenever it
comes to like shooters or anything that
requires precise aiming I always play on
PC but um yeah I imagine that playing on
console would be fine as well because
that that new patch - I think that for
the console versions they got much more
improved performance I think they think
that gave you 60 FPS on consoles y'all
can correct me if I'm wrong I think that
was an I was just paying attention to
the PC changes yes also all the changes
that I mentioned today they were I
believe PC changes not ps4 I mean I
imagine there's some crossover yeah
there is also a list of changes on the
ps4 if you are let's see if you all play
on console my bad for the ps4 bug fixes
in continued partnership s ie we have
been able to resolve the issue that
occurred for some Portenoy players in
which patches took longer to download
than they should
if you experience a reoccurrence at this
issue please reach out that's what it
says for ya so the the general there
were some general bug fixes outlined in
the very top of the patch notes if you
do visit their site the ones that I read
specifically were more for PC so all
those like weapon changes the Battle
Royale weapon changes yeah cross cross
console all right what kind of tactical
SMG see we got a suppressed SMG right
here that's coffee coffee with Jan says
yo I believe in you Michael
well wait coffee with Jan is that uh is
that the homie
janitrol from Giant Bomb it might be a
feed if that is you college boy
not it's all good
let me pull up real quick po up so they
say in the streets now is that what they
say in the rough streets of tomato town
yeah sure yeah yeah it's tough in tomato
town yeah it's rough in greasy Grove
greasy groan oh I don't I'm not
I ain't greasy I ain't dusty like that
fools who live over there and dusty
Depot and but I might want to move there
tilted towers yeah I move my ass all the
way out there umm if you guys stick
around we are gonna be looking at some
of the new skins soon you if you stick
around to you might get a and you're
gonna see me you might see Sam cat get
rekt but I'm just in case y'all didn't
know I'm setting the bar real low for
when she takes over thank you thank you
Michael it was very thoughtful of you
yeah which is why I hear I hear some I
hear some that drives me crazy the chest
noise like I hear it and I'm like I have
to find the chest to make it stop yeah
to find the chest to make it stop I
don't even necessarily need the chest I
don't necessarily care about having the
chest
I just need to make that glowing and
noise not to happen anymore yeah maybe
it's on the roof it's probably on the
roof it's probably in the Attic there
actually Oh what the hell yeah so like
make a no you're doing the most you
really are here no no I know exactly
where it is and you're not going there
destroyed the roof solve that problem
put your common drops man that's what I
know I feel you on that booty alright
wait is this thing this thing moving in
oh it's moving in I should probably move
it's not I'm not that far from the
search form Wow take is still
trash-talking from even behind the
camera
- you need a chill bro somebody else
said something nice in here I miss it
Oh Ben so that's that's something nice
Wow I thought you say something nice
before I forgot it and I forgot to shut
you out and I'm sorry oh thanks Ben our
own our own Ben Janka stop the
philanthropy the one the only he's known
around known around town is Phil
apparently whenever people call him that
I'm like about philanthropy should play
boy all right I think I'm I think I'm
good strapped up with uh with green salt
rifle sometimes I think I hear a chest
when I'm not even playing wow I I don't
blame you it got into my head so bad
last night that I was like like it
really it really did Oh what am i doing
shoot that tree well I thought I had my
pickaxe y'all played too much Michael it
is early in the morning man just get my
day started so don't blame me if I drink
your potion no I can't why I'm already
at max for the potion stuff I'm on slide
to the left slide to the right okay it's
weird how real been said it's a weird
it's a weird how real that name is she
was it is a weird I mean when you think
about it like eSports players they all
pretty much go by whatever handle they
gave themselves right that's how people
live just them I have a name handle
issue as well because what hammer yeah
well okay know that I made that choice
because my last name is like hammer but
nobody knows how to say it so it would
just constantly be this debacle so I was
like let me just make my my tag light
hammer and eventually people will get it
like they'll hear somebody say my name
oh that's why it's like hammer and then
all I get it and it actually worked
people know how to say my last name
without me even like telling me like
they're calling you by your handle but
that's actually your only Savior yes and
eventually a lot of people make the
connection which is great but before
that my gamertag was rose light because
well not everywhere but on League and so
a lot of people associated me with my
gamertag and call me rose
so it's like weird it's like this weird
issue now where like if you go to my
chat when I'm streaming the people call
me rose a lot of people still call me
rose and it won't make any sense to
people who know me as light hammer at
all because her name Rose like no no I
decided anyway your boy phil was
actually named Ben so anyway long story
short I feel you Ben I feel you mm-hmm I
just had a problem with like teachers
trying to say my damn last name right I
am you know
yeah that's what they would say it's
like yo the gh is silent yodel bro
arrange your inventory oh sorry yeah no
you're right you're right sorry I had to
interview yelling about it in the chat I
had to do something that there that's
how I'm gonna roll always have my main
weapon as three and a more powerful
weapon as four and the weapon I don't
really want to use at five two and one
can be whatever I don't really care my
fingers don't work like that what I'm
good thank you for you know you playing
you talk at the same time you kind of
forget what you're doing yes I had this
issue the very first shame I did hear
play battlegrounds I was looting I
believe I want to say 'la polka no no it
was the new map and it was that crash
site that like crater like plane crash
site right and I looted the whole town
like back and forth three times in a row
yeah because you're not even paying
attention
yeah you know and so they called me out
super-hard they were like what is she do
like she was just in that building and
I'm like yeah I was thank you for
pointing that out cuz I wouldn't have
noticed otherwise yeah
you're correct yeah so if you all want
to drop some tips Sam will call them out
for me if but when it comes down to it
it's all about aiming if I can't aim
then we ain't gonna win nothing but uh
we'll see you Oh
goob thank you for saying my last name
is awesome for a long time I didn't
think so because people made fun of it
oh oh look at this you know oh
Oh free-range chicken oh sorry that was
wrong game is that what is oh look at
this epic assault rifle oh yeah
let's go homie let's go I'm dropping
this I'm gonna snipe y'all - I don't
like this wait legendary your epic is
help go - oh why have medium bullets or
what's the legendary use what's what and
what is the legendary is medium also
medium yeah okay epic or why would why
would they tell you that there uses
medium bullets that they all use medium
bullets that seems look is then there's
light medium and heavy you see exactly
so art isn't heavy the best well heavy
weapons tend to shoot slower or I mean I
understand yeah so heavy is like they
shoot slower but they deal more damage
per bullet generally yeah and then like
the white ammo will you get more op more
opportunities to shoot but less damage
per I think perfect pistols and SMGs use
light bullets yeah and then yeah those
tend to shoot faster but I'm all about
them assault rifles he's gonna died
looting I know what people generally do
is build up walls when they loop but uh
for me I'm just like you know it's all
good I'm not tripping but that's that's
a bad way to think about it because I
have been wrecked many times not
watching my own bat not protecting
myself he wanted you to take the cold
one oh my god you know what sorry I used
that last night and I got a kill off it
and I I don't know if it was good yeah
that's a dead body you should be careful
ain't nobody gonna do nothing they
probably dipped out of here real quick
okay I mean I'm in the top ten I got one
kill so I feel pretty alright you know
this is as good as it's gonna get today
psych oh snap I hear some gunshots shots
is popping off
all right watch this oh nice nice I'll
playing this like poke do it do it do it
Oh ladies are these other two fools out
here only good look at this look at this
oh snap that was tied oh yes he is
building I dare you to peek out dog what
is he doing he's building he's probably
doing yeah ain't seen nothing watches oh
my god let's get right I don't know he
built that real nice so what am i good
job he can shoot through those like a
contender oh ho ho he's gonna be oh look
at this oh my god I love this watch this
oh my god all right
is your chance right it's duking it out
both yes redemption yes yeah with a
rocket launcher let's go
the focus sort of redemption spicy
my heart was being spicy my hands were
shaking but I'm still shooting and I'm
still getting the headshots like boom
headshot that was nice it was very nice
see those believe in yourself
III stayed calm though and I let I let
them let them like figure it out he's
got a you know Pleiku chill chill out
man that's what I say to myself whenever
I got oh do you see that what wait I'm
looking at my inventory I drop the
sniper firm rocket launcher I should
drop shot over there yes oh snap yeah
you're right I'm straight chill you're
gonna watch that go down I can't believe
you drop a sniper this would have been
perfect time for that maybe I should go
back and get it no I got it I got a
probably move soon so yeah in case they
want to want to step to this oh I think
see I'm not quick enough on the keys
it's only four of us left here so all
right if y'all got money on me or what
nobody trusts nobody believes you like
that yet mm-hmm watched a lot of fails
was all building up to this very moment
check this you just needed to warm up
that's what I'm getting at here all
right oh snap
where did that come from not behind you
no way no I know he's really not oh my
goodness came from like Northwest area
up there up on the hill like behind that
tree walking around with a damn med kit
um I'm a stranger I'm a chill out man
yeah you can probably like just like
look at the edges make sure there's a
couple was hella did you alright chat
y'all saw that my I didn't think that he
was there was because I saw the wall hit
it and I was like no he wouldn't stay
there if the wall if it was out of the
wall yeah that was just like press on my
part to assume that that's what was
happening
yeah hella behind you down misdirection
misdirection I was a full full
responsibility for them you know you
know you don't got to do that it's it's
it's on me to make sure I you know watch
my back you know I could have maybe I
could have built a wall in my back maybe
I could have got in a better position
maybe you know I don't know I did a lot
of make I'm we all make a lot of
mistakes is what I'm trying to say no
you made a mistake
good we're gonna wait here now for do
you want to actually exit out and see if
we can look at the shop or a look at
this building Oh too bad
yeah we're never gonna see who's the
winner nope we'll never know let's go to
the shop item shop and or this
items what kind of items do you guys
want to see I think if you click yes you
can get like an actual preview of some
of these items I don't know if they what
skins they want to see tax meter
Khaleesi if you're still watching and
periscope is still tuned in what kind of
skin C you want to see on periscope Air
Force One I think it's the Lunar New
Year's stuff yeah okay so go to I think
we should probably get Eric in here now
yeah so I mean you're gonna still be
streaming Sam's gonna be taking over
from here yeah while air coasts yeah
yeah thank thank you for watching me get
owned and thanks for all of your tips
that you were giving me in the chat now
it's your turn to give Sam tips as she
watching you get bombarded you know look
at oh my god look this dab emote for
5500 feet Buckskin out of here they
really do the most with these furros
they have the dab they do they do do the
most I don't know I don't know even when
I was playing destiny to I was like I'm
not not into emotes and stuff I'm all
about home ball about winning despite
what what y'all saw today mr. Krim says
you can assign walls and rams to your
mouse buttons I think that's probably
the best way to go about I have been
I've really messed I've still on default
controls I there's a lot of ways to
especially on PC there's a lot of ways
to make building a lot easier when you
do a lot of custom mapping on your stuff
so
I played this for about like 15 hours
and I still haven't done that but yeah
that's that's a good thing to uh to do I
ran I did assign ramps to a mouse button
last night and I thought it was a super
helpful
so do you are you gonna go on
exploratory mission to find Eric I don't
know I'm gonna I'm just gonna sign into
his dance right now okay all right well
with that I I am gonna dip out but Sam
is gonna be taking she's gonna be taking
over a game play and then you all will
get your boy that you get every day
Eric day so okay peace out y'all thanks
for watching me and critiquing my team
play it's all good love y'all thank you
so much Michael for playing this morning
you're the best
Eric is here okay we're gonna I'm gonna
move over hold on everyone else saw him
choke right I did we all was like four
people around my desk we're all watching
him I'm like dude he's in the top four
Rob's like he's gonna die cuz you know
the meta is in top ten usually is like
someone building like a huge-ass Howard
yeah and they weren't I was like dude
Rob he's good it's fine they're not
doing that and then all of a sudden he
turns a bat he's dead I feel so bad
because he knew it too and then I gave I
gave him the wrong call to action yeah
that's fine
streamers curse commentaries
commentators curse all right what are
you looking at
so periscope wants to see you skins and
I also think YouTube wants to see skins
okay the new lunar stuff get us out of
the way then real quick yeah and where
should I go in here because right now we
have I don't think we can we do have a
if we want to bring up a window we can
show them images of the skins not within
the client this is just like the
Valentine's suite let me figure that out
real quick man great did not plan for
that otherwise yeah we didn't really
plan to show you guys the new skins we
totally I can find I was talking to
Chris Pereira one of our news editors
and he says he has like like four skins
or like for pictures and total I'm
trying to find it though real quick
that's an update article right and then
we'll just bring it up for you guys so
you can see some of the new stuff try to
find it up there's that count those hold
up I can save these I would assume this
is one of them
I mean save that guy and let's see what
else does he have yeah I think he has
those like little Tower things that you
saw because there we saw festival
there's like the chest in there yes more
that has like gun skins but I think
those gun skins are for saved the world
and not Battle Royale
yeah but we'll show you guys them all
oops go back to yes and then maybe I'll
throw it somewhere in the middle and
hope that this doesn't break anything
no that's always the worry all right so
there's that we can make it fullscreen
for a moment if you want to make this
fullscreen yeah just give them like a
good quick look because I know there are
some people here that wanted to see this
can stop periscope so hey if you're
watching this you're listening here are
some of the new skins Chinese New Year
let me show you the weapon yes this is
this is for state of the world I believe
those are the weapon skins so there's
that one and then there's some of those
lunar skins for the characters I guess I
think there's like new possibly new
heroes to save the world but we're
playing battle royale just so you guys
know yes and then the towers that we saw
the towers in the game actually that we
just play they have the new towers with
the lanterns on them yes so that is
what's new for this give it a second
yeah well give you guys look damn Gube
wants the top three from you gosh gube I
don't know if I can even promise I don't
know if I can make any promises I only
stars in this game we'll see you never
know here's the weapons again that a
quick look
the beeps and then there's us if you
guys do want to read more about the
update the changes and see those images
again we have it all on site yep check
it out news page that is correct
all right back to the game yeah all
right man he was sitting pretty too
I was like man he's got this or at least
he's maybe getting a top three and then
Oh yep he had all the perfect like
scenarios - he had two people fighting
each other he just rolls up on him yeah
that was good that was hype yeah so
Michael has a 4 and a 6 today that's
pretty good I don't think I'd even come
close to that yeah that's really good
Michael
I felt bad we were all giving them such
a hard time and the chat was giving us a
hard time but anybody was pretty good
that's how it goes that's how it goes
you should be used to it hashtag Sam win
though you guys are gonna I'm gonna be
kind of derpy in this game especially
when it comes to the building but I saw
like I never played it and last time we
streamed this me and Michael I decided
to play and it was not if not a good
time but he kept draw he was like like
do you want to get spicy or you want to
play it slow like Poggi I was like now
let's just make it spicy so every drop
is like okay we're just gonna get into
one big one right away
bad decision it's okay please gamers
asking so are you guys willing to play
with viewers in the future right now we
don't have any plans for that currently
but you never know yes can't say never
yeah we don't want to say never we have
two plans or something like that but
perhaps so have you got the building
stuff down yet because that's like
that's like the evolution of this game
right it's like that becomes like I
don't know like the faster you build and
how high you can get to I don't know the
building I'm not that great at yet I do
like how it's already like pre toggled
on this mouse so I'll try my best
it's really good defensive strategy and
I get a little bit caught up in those
moments wanting to fight it yeah it
seems like it becomes pretty offensive
later but like it just depends I think
because like I don't know I've seen some
people kind of just build upwards so
that they can kind of
like shoot down at people that are
trying to like get to them too but so
I'm not gonna get first like the people
who dropped before me are gonna be here
way sooner than you know so I'm just
gonna see hopefully we'll see look at
all these people
it'll be fine no I'm gonna shoot for
this house right here except don't write
anybody is there yet I really don't like
dropping in this here we go why can't I
oh my god why is the why can't I use my
axe I'm so confused
is it because you still had to build
yeah that's weird oh I see okay I wasn't
used to sorry I was used to my controls
at home and I'm totally gonna get like
okay nice knowing you runnin
shake-and-bake by a he's got other
people to shoot each other
sorry I'm gonna go into that little
shack over here pretty fortunate that
you survive that somehow does anybody in
the office know high level building
strats oh I don't not really goob
maybe Aaron's done some a little bit but
not really I mean it's enough to try to
like learn to play the game but you know
like I said the evolution or the meta is
like one once you've gotten good at the
actual game then the next layer of that
is getting good at building and like you
know crazy jump pad
Mario's happens in this game for sure
who shield is good shield is always good
let's mark retail and go to fatal hey
man sometimes you got to improvise also
retail ro is a dangerous place later
George George will see if I can get
anything I'm gonna go up to that like
outlook over there oh god I'm gang shot
it yeah serpentine good thing you had
the shield
yeah good old bandage use useful
bandages snake snake Oh God
oh I saw a Shelly Romani oh okay they
have terrible aim that's just what we
have to keep continuing hope for oh boy
it's something anything but yeah they
are shoddy sniper explosive Ahmed's 5
MIT's les shields five things from
building towards me and there's someone
else shooting - I think at him or at
each other so let's just hope he's not
following you up this he's coming I
think I hear footsteps or maybe they're
finding each other and you can just find
a way to skirt out of here hopefully
hopefully hopefully hey how are you
celebrating Chinese New Year
um actually going to Disneyland tomorrow
we usually just have a lunch or dinner
call it a day nothing fancy same same
with the girlfriends family just usually
have a dinner with you know your
respective family is a slash extended
family you say gung hay fat choy you get
a red envelope and you get money nice
[Music]
like if you know somebody that like if
you get invited to it like a dinner of
like a friends who does celebrate
Chinese New Year this is probably a
decent chance you'll get something yeah
this is scary
you missed a chest in the tower well if
we did it's too late to go back for that
we got a white AR saying all right we're
not weaponless anymore which is good I
like how in this game though the guns
are already like pre-loaded whereas like
I always tend to forget in pub G to kind
of like yeah because like sometimes you
swap weapons right and you drop a weapon
for another weapon and then it's like oh
[ __ ] right I got to reload it again
I don't know I'm just running around and
not opening things the reason being I
was getting changed yeah I was trying to
get we're lucky to be alive
and we made 38 you made 38 that's pretty
good all things considered yeah that's
the start you yeah yeah no problem
Wow why was he not using a shotgun I
guess he was just did not see you coming
and just started to panic there good
good stuff there
shield is always good that we had shield
rather yeah yeah yeah first game first
kill no problem yeah you want the blue
er you know my assumption logically it
would it be that it does more damage and
then you know just like pub G shot like
I don't know I think in this game more
than Poggi shotgun like in a close
quarter is like really good yes I guess
also because you can have more weapons
in this game compared to pub gee that's
probably why shotguns get used more
where's like you know in pub G there's a
lot of people that rock you know double
AR or AR and sniper but you know I see
more shotgun play definitely in for
tonight than I do okay
it's cuz people are like jumping around
they just wanna get that like heavy day
I think they just wanna get the most
damage they can out of a somebody died
here I don't want the shotgun though
honestly like the reload time on that
was really killer and my what I like to
do is like when I'm shooting somebody I
just like to go back and forth like this
you see a scene you counter-strike
strafing almost yeah that was impressive
with a white argg well played it says
magic schism why thank you thank you
yeah blue a are more powerful yeah okay
good to know I am still beginner in this
game guys I'm coming out of good thing I
am - hahahaha but you know with our
power combined we're like maybe slightly
below average or at least average and
we're still in the circling to worry
about this got looted out already
oh I hear I hear a chest yeah also
apparently they said that the blue AR
also is more will be more accurate than
the white one
did you know purple
and I wanna did you know that the
circles on the oh there's a new grenade
that's the new grenade all right we
should try it probably OOP you dropped
your AR just I don't want that I mean I
don't you know let's get rid of this
thing yep
you know those little blue circles on
the walls those little blue circles if
you actually aim at them you'll uh
you'll break the things now faster
anyways she sees someone I'm gonna shut
up now shoot he just killed somebody and
I don't know he's gonna build up so be
careful all he wants Oh spicy okay are
you still over here that's fine Sam's
inching towards top 20 this is true
these are all true facts oh wait can we
use the grenade on that oh my god was
that a grenade oh the real Kendrick shot
Kendrick well see that's darn it I mean
like that's the that's the part of this
game is like the buildings slash aspect
though because verticality you can't you
can't necessarily do some of the stuff
you do here the puppy
but what I should what I should have
done is gone back there and then just
like launched is a pulse grenade at him
like a bun all of them yeah and then
that would have given me some buffer
time to heal up exactly dang that's
tough
gadge wants you to know Oh
humble oh well he's not humble
yeah people Kendrick man built a brick
house rooms
he was probably weak from potentially
finding that other person that you said
he killed so then he was probably like
walling himself off to heal up and then
once he healed up he obviously knew that
he he probably like he launched grenades
at you and so yeah not bad though not a
bad start it was like top 25 I think got
a kill white AR so somehow survived the
fatal fields with nothing just running
whenever I so I've only gotten well I
actually can't count the number of
chicken dinners I've gotten in poachy
it's pretty good but really no I I get
carried a lot in pub G took being
totally honest you can still say you got
dinners I did people have not gotten
well yeah I'm not saying I get carried
completely I do I'm gonna calling out
people yeah specially away I heard you
doing something for Michael earlier
because he was like wait what yeah like
no 3:30 yeah I have pretty good
peripheral so I'm mmm-hmm so I'm good at
that when it comes to actual PvP ice I
slept in the moment a lot I get like
'nygh a lick the panic the fighter
flight where you're like what do I do
what I do yeah and so that makes it hard
for me but when I'm in team settings I
think I'm a good team I try to be a good
team player
so when but I have on one occasion
gotten a solo chicken dinner
with no kills wait what I call it a
pacifist how did how how did the last
person died it died of his own yeah lie
in wait in the grass
is it was a cruelty-free chicken dinner
if you yeah that's fair I am gonna go to
salty springs oh did you yeah and then I
just continued to make it a joke that it
was like a I'm still salty so I'm gonna
go back to the salty springs so good
luck to you going to salty spring
alright I'm what
my dues I'm just gonna hit go straight
down I'm actually gonna do these
warehouses over there that I see because
okay muck the gamer nevermind for
tonight better on PC I think it's just
if you like mouse keyboard I think mouse
keyboard gives you better like you know
it's a personal preference thing but I
will say this is the fact that you know
it's free on PlayStation 4 it makes it
very accessible - it's gonna run
straight past it so you know there's
that oh people are dying yep this I'm
gonna die that way - so I'm just gonna
go over to that house over there oh my
god there's people over there - all
right time for a run we're gonna go for
a jog everybody oh wait that's just a
shield
Shaq's got something it's got a grenade
okay I can't build anything so how many
wood all right we're gonna chop this
tree down and try to get up there you
crazy
oh yeah so as I was mentioning Sam dough
circle you see that circle if you hit
the circle with the mouse like or aiming
your pickaxe it'll break it faster oh
good no yeah a vegan chicken dinner yeah
fairly accurate Keith Richards liver can
you can you just grab it by jumping
right now oh there's something in here
alright we're not I got a pistol
we'd be James Bond and got 50 shield I
think here in a second which is good
I got a pistola just kidding they know
where I am now it's it's like the throw
them off your scent that's exactly what
that was except now you're running to
where you threw the grenade right okay
we'll go this way there was a lot of
people this will be impressive if you
can handgun someone here not that I'm
telling you to do I'm just saying I see
something in that bill you have these on
me that's fine maybe there's no weapon
in there
yeah-yeah-yeah-yeah-yeah the anxiety I
have over just having this handgun right
now but there's a wall here people
thought well you got to remember a last
game you didn't have anything so until
later but uh you know just hope he
doesn't have a shotgun he or she does
have a shotgun and I think you'd be
maybe okay
oh what's that I'll take it well blue
something blue pistol better than our
current white pistol or common burn yep
who's playing the girl or the guy Sam is
currently or the guy
yes I'm is currently playing have names
that's true that's Sam I'm Eric I get
the luxury of just sitting back and
watching which is which is the dream no
pressure no nothing why open this when I
could just break it down for materials
you know again some bandages still no
luck with loot all right I'm just gonna
get into the circle here I know there's
somebody in that building I don't really
oh gosh where are they behind you
somewhere oh you are in shrubs oh my god
they were right behind them now
you can't like look behind you like you
oh you want that look back on while you
run yes
yeah I'm like so used I like hitting alt
and trying to look back and I'm like
where are they gonna play again happens
that's the beauty of battle royale game
as long as you it is you just hop back
in and call it a day you hope for the
best
we're good stuff yes yeah yeah I mean
that was uh that was a game that's what
you guys do so I was telling Michael in
the beginning that I as somebody who's
put a fair amount of time and to
battlegrounds it's been like my game of
choice basically for the last six months
that's fair
I was definitely clowning on for tonight
for the majority of that time that's
fine but but last night yeah I was
playing and at first I was like this
game is stupid like tomato town yeah so
you worried about the cartoon aesthetic
the saddle bus you know and I was just
like what is this child's play yeah
version I started having fun uh-huh
and I was like so I di with the draw the
the crap I gave fortnight in the
beginning because it's actually a really
fun game I'm just all right cuz I you
said okay so I had the same mentality
like way back in the day cuz I played
dota 2 or dota and dota 2 I was like
League what a kids game League yeah and
I still do this day have not played
League so let's go dota whoa no not at
all dota makes me a dota kind of like
overwatch like it got to a point where
at least overwatch competitive where it
just wasn't as fun anymore especially
like spending 30 40 minutes at a time
and then kind of like just like nothing
coming out of that it was just too too
much to bear and to rage inducing so
kind of got off that wagon
all right blue shotgun which is a great
start
yes at least compared to last game so I
played here somebody ninja is one of the
best players yes I see there's a loot
crate there too to your right
sorry right there to your right yeah
you'll need that for later potentially
okay that's my fault her death is my
fault I told her about the ham hook
crate hey someone else just talked about
the ammo crate don't look at me like
that
hey next time don't pick up ammo then I
guess still still mad still she's still
upset she's still upset that's fine Hey
Oh perfect I had a blue I took I took
the blame for it I said if she died here
it's my fault because I told you to pick
up the arm okay but I was saying that
because in chat last time they said you
should pick up the ammo crate cuz it's
gonna help you get down the road so I
don't know maybe me and chat are to
blame I blame all of you it's none of my
fault okay the round right I mean she
did have a blue shotgun Kaylie Marie
Rose Baker's this low I'm new and I am
now subscribing welcome to the stream
kala Kaylee Kaylee
I would I think so I'm just not gonna
try to butcher yeah yeah thank you for
subscribing is not the best bra okay I
said one of the best but again who knows
like that's just from a streamer
perspective probably who knows how many
great amazing 49 players there are in
the world that don't stream this is true
there's probably a ton I always thought
about this with League of Legends
because like I so all right let's talk
League I can talk to me okay so with
League that was like my game for years I
played League like obsessively for like
five or six years okay
and I wasn't like super super in eSports
I did follow I did follow it though okay
so it's not like I didn't follow it sure
I definitely paid attention and I knew
who liked the challenger players word
that were actually pro players and
there's always like that one challenger
player who you're like who are they they
don't play pro yeah but they're like
number they're like on the top
20 like you're like who is he yeah why
is he not a prayer why is he not getting
why is not making money off of this you
know yeah
oh it's jumped out with a ton of people
like this oh dang yeah there's a lot
we're gonna retail ro all right we're
hoping no I'm gonna go towards these
warehouses over here okay yeah it would
always drive me crazy I'd be like who
are all these pros I mean like people
who should be yeah K X just so you know
Sam's got like a few hours under her
belt I've barely I played like a like
half an hour the one time duty stream
wasn't very good at it did finally get a
kill it took like half an hour I think
ooh oh yeah that's good I don't know
what that is
it's the crossbow which apparently this
time around is supposed to be they drop
less compared to before that's part of
the patch update but we got a purple
crossbow which is interesting analysis
here there's lots of people here
actually yeah but you got a purple
crossbow they better watch out pistol
and they it's a revolver too they're not
good I don't I would assume that okay
if you're looking by score myth is not
the best there isn't it I'll let you
guys debate who the best player is I'm
really not worried about that right now
all right all right what is that is that
the bursty Auto rifle that you have it's
like the pulse rifle from destiny it
shoots like burst firing yeah oh there
is some action going on all right
popping shield I should have been
jumping around that is something I'm not
used to is like people really like jump
around a lot in this game and I'm
sitting here just like trying to shoot
and I'm not used to the pulse I don't
like that as much yeah
I wanted you to go full Rambo there and
use the cross now
I should have drink again
um please camera I pulled up the pickaxe
to break through the wall I pulled the
weapon back on afterwards never played
for a night I only know it as I watched
my brother play oh well thank you for
coming by watching us play we play other
games besides for a night to hear it's
your first time here and just a reminder
to all like the newcomers we stream
every day Monday through Friday around
11 a.m.
yep for one to two hours playing
different games every day if you guys
are not in a fortnight but you're here
tomorrow we're gonna be playing some
Monster Hunter not me Benjamin and John
Luke will be here playing some Monster
Hunter if you guys are into that mm-hmm
and I believe I'm gonna double-check
there should be a bonus stream tomorrow
for Bayonetta slash Bayonetta 2 because
it's out on the switch tomorrow okay so
everybody is like a lot of people drop
as soon as they can so this should be
quite spicy okay so you want to get
spicy good luck to you in this little
field maze was like all right on the
edge good lucks got some nice little
roof it's all mine oh hello who will win
you're already doing a better job than I
did last time I had to pick fights yep
gatim ha ha panda jumper oh nice good
thing he didn't go up there there's
shotgun there's a shield oh yeah that's
good we need that bow show muck the
gamer said I supp thank you for subbing
yes thank you for the subs Monster
Hunter world Monday got replaced with
destiny boo no that's not true please
gamer 100 world Monday's got moved to
Friday so as Monster Hunter world Monday
is now on Fridays so no sir I'll hearth
II I I don't appreciate this the skip
we'll see we'll see if you're right or
wrong what are you gonna do if you're
wrong right I bet she will die in the
first five minutes is what he wrote I
think that she's gonna probably I think
I'm I'm feeling a top like top 30 maybe
if someone came in here huh
possibly I'll watch out then someone
might be upstairs I need a shotgun use
the shotgun or use the revolver on them
thank you oh I'm sorry I'm laughing
because that guy looked like he cycled
through like multiple weapons and never
got a weapon let's see she showed me she
was like I don't want the shotgun I'm
just gonna use a you use this trusty old
revolver I think that I think five is a
assault rifle with a scope oh yeah some
assault rifles have scope some don't oh
okay so I didn't actually like it
personally when uh I picked one up but
that's just me I could really use your
chest don't know let's see it's probably
upstairs there's like an attic up there
yeah there is oh god
we're behind hey we got two kills and
technically that one person was right
but I was right I died in the first five
minutes but technically you got to say I
wanted to prove him wrong so bad I know
I should just camp the house then my
hand I should have you're right
again when you have a real good loadout
and died immediately yeah I don't yeah I
wasn't feels it was pretty good it
wasn't amazing chest is on the roof yeah
oh she knew she was on her way to
getting it it was heading up there yeah
every cameras nightmare yeah so what
have you been playing lately these days
uh Monster Hunter yeah um it spilled my
my destiny pitch but I'm actually kind
of slowly getting bored of 100 and I
know why I just kind of
I don't know I shouldn't have beat the
game I guess you kind of have to keep
playing the endgame part of it but I
felt like Zelda like when I began and I
kind of stopped playing it and kind of
regretted beating ganon I should have
just kept playing the game and milking
it for as long as I could and I was like
I don't care about the rest these moons
yeah cuz apparently yeah in that game
especially like the route like the more
there's more stuff like after this story
like just to do all the the moons and
then get to like what the other side of
the Moon and I don't know there's just a
bunch of stuff lots of moons there are
like I thought that there were only a
few hundred moons apparently there's
like over a thousand moons in the game
yeah cuz you can also buy them too yep
yeah alright alright what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna ride this to the end all
the way okay and hope that the circle is
in your favor yes I'm gonna try to get
to the top of that hill actually I've
never done that and I know they say high
ground is not great in the beginning but
I also just like don't care and I kind
of want to see what's up there yeah Alex
Munoz Monster Hunter probably won't be
out for PC until like August ish is a
roughly the time frame Jordan 95m hello
welcome to the stream welcome welcome
goob yep same thing I've heard began and
lost the urge to play yep that makes
sense
TIPA near monster hunter fo life yo yeah
I think I just got switch weapons I
think that's the next evolution alright
here we go we're going to a rickety old
house beat that guy to the house I think
you're going to don't let you down
alright I'm probably gonna get there at
the same time as him do you guys have
discord groups we have like our own
internal oh watch out okay pick ax fight
number two we're swinging haymakers it's
real close oh and Sam takes out captain
Jimbo go to the house okay
we're going somewhere else heck no heck
no don't die to fall damage hey you're
two for two for pickaxe bites which is
pretty good I probably would have died
put the brakes on pump the brakes on
like sieve right now for me like seeing
all these mushrooms is just making me
want to pick them up but like you can't
do that I try but that's that Monster
Hunter life that monhun like breaking
trees Wayne scared we don't care if you
have weapons like I don't even know how
to get down right now I'm like on a
cliff right here you got a build or you
got trees yeah as somebody mentioned to
you know obviously breaking stuff does
alert people so you know hopefully they
don't well know that you're don't they
know I'm here now all right let's do
this
I'm feeling pretty decent a slide that
way well you had it oriented at one
point or you just go back up to the
house and hope that the guy's not at the
house or yeah all right time to go up we
going up oh I could rotate it I got it
no I can't you can't go down okay that's
cool we were also told you could just
build platforms I guess to get across
yeah it's fine we got 81 more to spare
they'll never expect us to go back to
the house that's definitely not what
they're expecting real wolf I would
assume it's still retail which would be
probably roughly $60 from Monster Hunter
well yeah okay here we go here we go
let's Prelude it uh yeah oh maybe not I
don't know unless it the person was
doing a good job of like actually
closing doors I feel like this house is
is all you yeah I got a pistol now yeah
it's all got TAC shotgun I don't hear
any chest it's white better than Green
Green is better than white gotcha okay
the house was definitely not looted but
there's like nothing in it yeah and all
right get in the car just kidding I wish
you got to build your way that's your
mobility all right we're gonna build out
all right let's do it
building our way down the hill okay
we're gonna look so ridiculous that's
fine I don't even care what's monster
hunter world like it's like any other
monster hunter more or less you go hunt
big monsters but you look real cool and
fashionable doing it most of the time
and you have a cool little cat that you
can dress up to later Kaylie Marie Rose
Baker thanks again for subbing and we'll
see you tomorrow I won't see you and Sam
we'll see you but our compatriots will
see you tomorrow so please stop by nice
save that's another way you can do it I
think you can slide and then build under
yourself as you slide all right let's
try that in action let's see are we good
to take the safe route real safe I was
gonna like jump off a cliff and then
like nope nope
12 damage sitting on eight life but in
the in the top 40 Oh a bad feeling about
this in terms of how far you got to go
me too me too
there's definitely people here there's a
fall damage forgiving or never mind yeah
isn't too bad one tap and you're dead do
you hear that gonna fire yeah good oh
this fancy ass house yeah no see there's
ain't bandages in here no there's not I
don't think there is it probably took
the box hello
where were you standing at right behind
that no way let's see is there a death
cam can you see how yeah I don't think
so darn it I have no idea how he killed
you actually trap oh you think so maybe
yeah
actually maybe because there there was
an item there
using the trap all right well you place
thirty-two I think we have time for one
more if you want or we can call it it's
up to you I was so startled much such
startled much well yeah much Wow alright
we turn to lobby we'll do it again all
right last one
Sam the man Gigi you know guys deathtrap
I hate you all for watching me play some
for tonight today it definitely takes
some getting used to but I like it
yeah I actually like it I'm gonna play
more I take back everything I said I
will never do that about League take it
back
I won't look I'm even wearing a Leona
pin today I was like dude you can so
like in my mind I'm like oh cool you get
a flash right from the start that's a
that's a 2100 gold investment in DotA
that thing is called a blink dagger yeah
and you know what I actually do sir I'm
critical of League like in a lot of ways
I think it's so stupid they like they
even make flash an option like it's
totally become a mandatory part of the
game
but for some reason summoner spells are
still thing like I I don't know I'll
never understand certain choices that
are made but I mean some of it I mean I
guess kind of makes sense like there's
someone to summon your spell's I just
feel like flash is like it's it's it's
just like the thing that you have to do
true there yeah I guess so huh yeah do
you think that like all five positions
yeah okay think of a reason why you
wouldn't take flash that's a hot take
league is bad yeah let's go Ben we're
getting it flame though i praetor thank
you for coming to the stream season here
let's see how she does in her last run
good luck good luck to Sam here she is 2
for 2 on the pickaxe fights if I feel
like if she has to fight with her
pickaxe I'm gonna give her the bed you
just been around them they're like so
they miss see you last time I was
jumping around like an idiot trying to
pick accent I don't think that's the
strategy I think this guy's gonna go
past these houses rift League I don't
league's weak still healthy and fine
yeah Golden State Warriors has a
come on I challenge your team I don't
see anybody going for these I hate the
parachuting now I have to say it's
you're not yeah I wasn't the gliding or
whatever it's so oh no it's a small
shield some Ambo nishan uh jaws of
Hannah we mostly I don't know we just
prefer the battle royale mode I don't
know yeah there were some people that
played the save the world mode but
definitely the popularity for this game
definitely has been the battle royale
mode for sure mm-hmm
I think battle royale is like the thing
right now it is the new MOBA as I would
like to say or the new hero shooter is
though Battle Royale
I feel like shoot shake and bake there
behind you you're generally not gonna
kill them from that far but maybe you
got hit markers so I could be wrong
sadly I don't think you run faster -
without the with the pickaxe out or
whatever but you know all right you're
gonna I'll play this person I have a
feeling okay come for me
you'll never know
someone says you're dead meat I think
mm-hmm I don't hear the are they trying
to outwit you totally they stopped
walking did you have time to drink your
shield potion again watch this
the moment she does this she gonna die
and it's gonna be my fault okay
this day I'm just head shot that dude
across the mat with a shotgun I'm not
sure I did hit him yeah you for sure he
got hit markers I don't know if okay
Sam stem killed you I already I really
don't like the shotgun really I think
the reload time
well that one oh that one is the it's
like there is an auto shotgun I think
the tack shotgun is the auto shotgun
that shotgun kills me it kills me inside
well then next time you can use your
pickaxe while he shoots you in the face
yeah you know what
pickaxe oh he is like what I've learned
from today yeah I will give you one more
go Michael is gonna walk around like a
boss today he always walks around like a
boss so just his his persona so to speak
Erik can we have a moment of silence for
the start of the stream when I was
confused because the browser window was
up yes I was like leave you I'm like oh
let me go help you with that and then
the moment I got in here it was like oh
it's all good alright yeah later
one day I'm gonna start out Thursday
without a hitch it's gonna be smooth
like butter I'm looking forward to it
it's gonna be good practice makes
perfect right it's so funny because it's
so simple to well you know midnight I do
not disagree yeah we gonna we gonna do
something about that guy oh no it's you
know look I'm not gonna pretend I'm
great again I don't need that toxicity
don't need that computer in our lives
okay I played 10 matches and I died like
every I'm like I don't think I got a
kill for like seven of them so you know
thank you thank you for the for the new
subs guys we appreciate variants of tase
buttons that's right I know I have no I
have definitely messed up days buttons
I've actually moved some of them so that
there is no way anyone can alright well
there's not that there's no way but
there's less likelihood of people
potentially pressing the wrong button
so there's that strongly dislike the
paraglider yeah I don't like it not a
fan of the paraglider or whatever
contraption in school yeah call it a
glider glider the chute yep
the shoot the chute well that's half
true
please gamer I'm not the IT guy here
though basically a gun ah you did do
better what they were Evolver than the
shotguns yeah I guess even though I told
you to use the shotgun maybe you should
just use it use what yeah use your good
eye like there's a circle yet cool 20
more seconds yeah so thanks KX label
makers your friends see the fun fact
about the stream deck thing the
al-ghanim deck is the buttons actually
have labels on them like as an LED so
like one of them says like live loop one
of them says intro one of them says
camera all of the information for me to
achieve is their bandages I'm excited
hey we haven't had bandages in like
three games I'm excited okay that's fair
then please give me this is good a
long-distance revolver Oh breaks down oh
he's got like SMD schwifty Oh mine too
yep some type of assume is that it is
that like the sad and I mean I can give
you another go I can totally give you
another I can't I can't handle two
failures in a row like that that was
that's fine
we made it spicy yeah it was fun we had
a good time good fights there Michael
had a really hot run in the end you know
reclaim me was yeah many choked now you
didn't really choke cause you never saw
the guy yeah
but thank you guys for tuning in today
to watch some for tonight and you know
let's talk about the update and the the
new game changes we stream every day if
you're new here at 11 o'clock Monday
through Friday and you should check in
tomorrow for Monster Hunter if you're
into that and if you're here for the
first time please sup
mm-hm and as your resident social media
person I should tell you guys to go like
us on Facebook and follow us on Twitter
Instagram and you know if you use up
news in the morning check that out yeah
of course and you know just so you guys
know every Thursday should tune in
because Sam will be here playing
different types of games you can hang
out with her every Thursday so thank you
guys all for tuning in thank you Sam for
playing
[Music]
[Music]